hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
videos möchte mit heute rollt was habe
ich für einen scheiß ich möchte euch
heute eine story erzählen die glaube ich
sehr vielen von euch weiterhelfen wird
im leben deswegen würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt räume
ich bin jetzt nicht so wie ein paar
andere youtuber die euch jetzt sagen ja
ich hatte schon die ganzen straftaten
meinem leben begann und die und die
schlägerei hatten wir da und da über
sowas habe ich natürlich auch schon in
anderen videos geredet aber um jetzt so
ein komplettes video mit irgendwas zu
füllen
da habe ich mir einfach jetzt gerade
gedacht okay mir ist dafür was passiert
vielleicht hilft es einigen von euch
weiter ihr müsst wissen ich bin
aufgewachsen im vorort von bielefeld und
bin da halt auch zur schule gegangen und
es gab halt dann irgendwann so die
weiterführende schule da bin ich auf ein
gymnasium gegangen und es gab zwei
gymnasien so die auch so ein bisschen
rivalität immer hatten aber ich hatte
halt ein paar freunde halt auf einer der
auf dem anna gymnasium hier war ich da
war das animierte paar freunde und hier
halt eigentlich und die hauptsächlichen
freunde als die meisten meiner die
handkante aus der schule und so
jedenfalls war auf dieser schule als auf
der anderen schule allein ein junge in
einer höheren stufe als es viel zu
kompliziert ich hatte früher ein kumpel
und der warten nicht gerade dünn und der
bauch der anderen schule und war eine
stufe höher als ich also älter als ich
und der wusste nicht was er machen
sollte in seinem leben und darum geht
sollte ich werde keine namen nennen
sondern einfach mal so die story so ein
bisschen erzählen und vielleicht einigen
von euch da draußen zum denken anzuregen
so ein bisschen im leben weiter zu
helfen aber ich fange jetzt erst mal das
war irgendwie 2013 oder 2014 kurz vor
meinem abi oder so werden sich auf einer
party kennengelernt unterhalten blabla
und ist ein sehr netter kerl gewesen
hört sich irgendwie so anders geht die
story in die richtung okay dann habe ich
mich in ihn verliebt oder ja oder ist
gestorben
nein darum geht es nicht wie war doch
irgendeiner party und haben uns darüber
unterhalten so über was von sicherheit
zu unterhält man lernt sich gerade
kennen labert so ein bisschen über die
party bei ein paar leute über bisschen
keine radio party machen
alkohol schule etc pp und irgendwann
unterhält man sich einfach so darüber ja
was machst du nach dem abi weil das war
halt so wirklich kurz vorm abi jahre
wieder was auf jeden fall 2014 ist halt
wissen zu haus bei mir ist es irgendwie
fast jeder weiß dass ich ihn bei youtube
mache ich habe es keinen erzählt sondern
ich will lieber nicht so haben dass es
so keiner weiß von da aber ist lässt
sich halt einfach nicht vermeiden
irgendwie hatte früher auch irgendwie so
viele anfragen von lokalen zeitungen
bekommen so jung du bist ja aus der
region richtig krass ey ist größer als
ein interview mit dem akja und alles
abgelehnt weil ich bin erstens nicht so
ein typ und zweitens wollte halt einfach
nicht dass viele wissen dass sich
youtube mache jedenfalls wusste er dass
halt auch und dann haben uns darüber ein
bisschen unterhalten und dann hätte er
so auch wie gern hätte ich auch so was
was ich richtig gut kann was mir spaß
macht was ich dann später als beruf
machen kann und dann habe ich ihm so
gesagt das war immer leuten sagt die
nicht wissen was sie später machen
sollen und zwar so wie es irgend was
finden und mache auf jeden fall was was
dir spaß macht weil es gelte scheißegal
ich bin halt wirklich so der kompletten
überzeugungen dass man etwas machen
sollte wolle man spaß hat weil wenn als
einen spaß macht irgendwie mit klötzchen
zu spielen dann kannst du daraus
schliessen ok max vielleicht weder spaß
eine mauer zu bauen oder sowie solltest
vielleicht bauarbeiter werden obwohl er
dann sagt da verdient man noch nicht so
viel wenn man gut in etwas ist für die
man in jeden scheiß job viel es ist
einfach so ich haben uns auf jeden fall
so von meinem leben erzählt so dass sich
als youtube mache dass ich das wäre
spaßmachers ich mir vorstellen kann dass
auch später als beruf zu machen was ich
jetzt derzeit zwar im detail studiert
hat noch nebenbei und das finanzierten
oder studium und so weiter und er war
halt irgendwie so total leide schon mal
ordentlich dann auf so was und dann habe
ich mir halt gedacht okay bruder macht
das worauf du bock hast wirklich ziehe
das durch und am ende sehr weiß nicht
was ihm spaß mache dann habe ich gesagt
okay wir überlegen jetzt mal was du gut
kann es beziehungsweise was du gerne
macht und daher beschlossen okay wir
treffen uns irgendwie zwei drei tage
später und gehen einfach mal zusammen
sein alltag durch und danach zusammen
okay was hat er an
tag gemacht was er gern gemacht was hat
er nicht gemacht blablabla drehtag ich
bin auf jeden fall morgen zu ihm gerade
rippen fahrrad und er hatte irgendwie
schon schon frühstück vorbereitet und
sonntag hatte das team die tolle
hingestellt mit mit rührei und wartete
alles gemacht aber auch ultra cool oder
wir halt es einen kompletten tag
verfolgt weil man irgendwie erst ein
bisschen zocken dann sind wir zusammen
noch zu meiner kollegen gefahren waren
dann noch mal was essen und da war mit
ihm in seinem restaurant oder so ich
wollte eigentlich döner essen geht der
canton coolen laden gestalten dass es
irgendwie ganz cool weil man da halt
noch was ist aber die hat er darüber
unterhalten okay was machen wir gerade
machen typische lidl sachen die leute
halt machen so zocken irgendwie
fahrradfahrens freude und gehen was
essen und am ende des tages eine bahre
gang war noch was trinken und dann bin
ich halt jemand abends nach hause
gefahren und habe gedacht okay das war
sehr ernüchternd weil wir haben es halt
so ausgemalt ok wir finden bestimmt
irgendwas wo wir beide sehr okay das
macht ihm spaß das kann er sich
vorstellen irgendwo zu studieren oder
eine ausbildung zu machen oder so aber
dass es war nicht der fall
wir haben nichts gefunden wo wir direkt
hätten sagen würden okay das kannst du
gut dass platt bla bla bla bla bla
jeder meiner freunde sagt mir
beispielsweise ich rede viel zu viel und
kommen nie auf den punkt oder meinten
folglich auch du musst unbedingt jetzt
radio oder irgendwas machen und das ist
glaube ich ein bisschen so der grund
warum ich youtube mache nur um euch zu
zeigen worauf wir achten wollen
natürlich wollten jetzt nicht irgendwas
sehen von wegen okay er sieht jemanden
und sagte wow das ist toll so was muss
ich machen sondern ich wollte mir doch
die kleinen sachen achten so werden wir
beispielsweise aufgefallen wäre wie es
läuft oder die er redet oder so da kann
man ja direkt schon sagen okay dass die
geile stimme macht synchronsprecher oder
so jedenfalls sahen wir dann beide so
ein bisschen nicht aber traurig dass wir
nicht zu ihm gefunden haben
ich bin einer wieder nach hause gefahren
abends lag im bett hat mir dann gedacht
hey ich habe heute richtig geiles
gefressen ich bin mir angekommen hatte
frühstück vorbereitet hat nun übels
geiles frisch gekocht dann sind wir
nicht zu in dem dönerladen mittags
gegangen sondern in restaurant wo die
leute echt geiles essen machen uns das
geil servieren ok am abend eigentlich
nur noch von den müssen in der bar
ernährt aber das ist was das ist was
anderes und dann habe ich ihm das
einfach mal gesagt und dann ist uns
aufgefallen
er frisst einfach gern er ist gerne
essen er bereitet es gerne zu
er hat spaß daran er geht lieber in ein
restaurant alt sind irgendeinen
komischen dönerladen um die ecke oder
habe ich ihn einfach gesagt okay wir
zwar den tag gesehen wir haben jetzt
nichts gesehen okay du guckst dahin und
machst dies und macht das gut sondern
einfach nur du magst essen macht da was
raus und gerade geht er zur culinary
arts academy in switzerland also in der
schweiz er geht da gerade zu dieser
hochschule für kochen schokolade und so
einen chat soll überhaupt keine werbung
für diese hochschule seinen warum
scheint denn jetzt die sonne hier so
perfekt rein gerade soll wirklich
überhaupt keine werbung für die
hochschule sein ich weiß nicht ob sie
gut oder schlecht ist er ist auf jeden
fall gerade das ist ein kumpel von mir
und ich weiß gar nicht genau wie das
ganze video hingehen soll ich habe mir
einfach mal gedacht ich bekomme so auf
die frage gestellt und habe jetzt auch
gerade wieder eine mail bekommen von
wegen joker hier ich weiß was ich machen
soll hat es nicht mal youtube kanal in
die rechnungen oder soll orientiert euch
nicht zu sehr an dem was andere machen
also er meinte ja zu mir dass youtube
kanal ist voll cool er will auch
irgendwie sowas machen und wir haben
dann fahren sie einfach sonntag zusammen
verbracht und mir dann hat jemand
aufgefallen er mag nicht gern essen das
hat sich total bescheuert an und ich
weiß viele werde jetzt wahrscheinlich
hatte sagen hatten
allerdings soll auf videos ein bisschen
die message rüberbringen wenn ihr
wirklich nicht wissen was sie nach der
schule machen sollte teure hauptziel in
eurem leben gut können oder so setzt
euch einfach mal hin mit einem kumpel
der beobachtet euch dann kommt man immer
auf irgendwas weil jeder mensch kann
irgendetwas gut und alle an
sie lagern aidoo kannst nicht so dass
die reden nur scheiße alle reden
eigentlich nur scheiße damit wird jetzt
auch das video hätte meine damen und
herren das war so ein bisschen story
teil wir heute mal wieder bei ich das
unbedingt erzählen wollte diese story
wenn euch das video gefallen habe ich
mich über die bewertungen freuen ich
hoffe es konnte vielleicht ein paar von
euch ich sag mal weiterhelfen nach dem
motto okay ich weiß nicht was sie nach
der schule machen soll dann noch wohl
durch einen freund überlegt einfach und
denkt an die subtilsten sachen wären
dann herausgefunden dass er gerne ist
wie bescheuert hört sich das an aber
jetzt geht er auf eine fucking
fachhochschule warum schule oder
hochschule oder für essen zu kochen du
einfach kann's gehen freunde
es muss nicht sein du kannst gut reden
oder hey du siehst gut aus oder so ist
sind so einfache sachen ich hab' ich
gerade glaube ich komplett bescheuert
wieder motivation menschen oder so aber
will ich gar nicht sein ich wollte das
heute mit euch teilen